the paparazzo hit by Justin Bieber
shares a recovery update after the car
collision shot good as anything
everybody hour before my birthday hits I
get ran over by Justin Bieber in that
something Bieber was leaving the city
church service in Beverly Hills
Wednesday night when he accidentally
struck photographer Maurice Lamont with
his black pickup truck I think the truck
was a little bit too big for him though
because there's no way he could see over
the front it was the slope it was on but
like I said he got out he was
compassionate he's a good kid accidents
happen
authorities told ET the 57 year old man
was transported to a local hospital with
non-life threatening injuries in the
caption of the clip from his hospital
bed maurice even wrote I wish Bieber was
still on tour he'll give me
[Music]
the incident comes just a day after the
pop star announced he was cancelling the
remainder of his purpose world tour due
to unforeseen circumstances now a source
close to Bieber tells ET quote it just
came down to him being sick and tired of
being on tour he lost his enthusiasm
adding justin stress and anxiety just
got to him and he couldn't handle it
anymore
[Music]